ISSA DEE: My life was all over
the place. I was broke.
I was crashing as Daniel's.
You should've just stayed
with me.
Nah, girl. Remember that week
I stayed with you back in '05?
-You just gonna act like--
-I didn't do shit to your vase.
♪ That chick, tryna do it right
When I pull up ♪
ISSA: You can't keep letting
other people prop you up.
Sometimes you gotta do shit
for yourself.
I'm about to throw
a block party.
You'll need a form for each act.
Some of the acts are TBD,
but I'm on my way to DMing them.
(LAUGHS)
♪ Oh, baby, let's play tag ♪
Which one is Andrew? Is he
the black one or the Asian one?
-MOLLY: The Asian one.
-Just try it out.
Sometimes people can
surprise you.
Like Nathan.
-How do you know when its real?
-It feels...
-pretty real to me.
-Yeah it does.
♪ I got too much sleep
Last night! ♪
Beyoncé or bust, bitches!
Bitch, I got like three hours
of sleep last night.
-What the hell's wrong with you?
-I'm gonna fry your face
you bang those pans
one more time.
ISSA: We came here to have
a good time
and celebrate Tiffany.
This the last weekend
before you get boring.
I'm just gonna get more...
responsible.
I came to par-tay.
I could still drop it low.
You just gotta help me up
though.
You feeling better?
Ever since I got pregnant,
I just feel so left out.
-Everything's different now.
-We don't have to be.
-And we'll always be friends.
-Yeah, I hope so.
Lawrence.
What have you been up to?
(BLOWS RASPBERRY)
LAWRENCE:
I'm 32 years old.
I can't keep doing that shit.
Lawrence,
would you take Issa back?
Hell nah.
I should probably go say
hi to Lawrence.
Good seeing you... again.
-How was Lawrence?
-I think I'm over him.
Nathan better know how lucky
he is.
-What's wrong with you?
-Nathan hasn't been picking up?
He hasn't hit me back
in a minute.
What are y'all doing out here?
Why weren't we on
your planning committee?
Blair asked to do it,
and she's a mother.
So, I just thought she'd be
helpful.
Because I don't have a baby
I couldn't do that for you?
ISSA: This block party,
I just wish we could get,
-like, a really big headliner.
-What do you mean wish? We are.
Thank you for meeting up
with me. Do you need a lift?
CONDOLA: No, I'm good actually.
I have a date.
I thought maybe
I scared you away
-when I told you I was divorced.
-Nah.
Nathan showed up at your house,
and I sent his ass on away
with the quickness.
You should've just told me
and let me handle that myself.
Like how you handled going over
his house?
You came after me
and then you just left.
I'm back here now... for good.
ISSA:
I just need some time...
to figure out what I want.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪